[Musica]
[Applauso]
Chi di voi ha mai visto o conosce questo
pesce qui Proviamo a fare per alzata di
mano Ok magari qualcuno l'ha visto per
mare altri lo conoscono bene dai
guardatevi intorno tenete la mano alzata
quanti l'hanno alzata Ok perfetto
qualche mano su perché di voi non lo
conoscesse ve lo dico subito questo qui
è il pesce luna è il più grande pesce
osseo che esiste sulla terra Quindi un
pesce con le spine
questo pesce è una visione molto comune
per chi vive il mare
spesso lui nuota molto lentamente e
quindi animali altre alghe si attaccano
sulla superficie del corpo e allora lui
che è molto furbo per liberarsene si
sdraia di lato sulla superficie del mare
a prendere proprio il sole aspettando
che i raggi solari brucino questi
animali oppure che altri animali come i
gabbiani li possono mangiare perché poi
alla fine non ho ancora ben capito se
per pigrizia per astuzia la natura trova
sempre le soluzioni più pratiche
dovremmo veramente prenderla come
esempio
molti di voi oggi hanno alzato la mano è
vero perché il pesce luna con le sue
Pine che sembrano un po' quelle di uno
squalo è un pesce che si vede spesso Da
chi Da chi Naviga il mare Eppure questo
pallino grigio qui ci dice tutt'altro
questo bollino viene dalla lista Rossa
dell'aiussienne l'unione internazionale
per la conservazione della natura dove
tutte le specie esistenti sulla terra
vengono classificate in non a rischio a
rischio o in pericolo in via
d'estinzione
il pesce luna però come più di 13.000
altre specie solamente nel mar
Mediterraneo rientra in quest'altra
categoria data definite data carenti
Ciò vuol dire che la comunità
scientifica non ha abbastanza
informazioni seppur sia un pesce che sia
vista spesso per sapere se questo
animale è in via d'estinzione oppure no
solamente nel mar Mediterraneo una ogni
6 specie marine rientrano in questa
categoria e se non sappiamo dove sono e
come stanno non possiamo proteggerle
il mare è grandissimo lo sappiamo bene
copre il 71% della superficie del nostro
pianeta è profondo in alcuni luoghi più
di 10 km
Eppure gli scienziati stimano che ne
abbiamo scoperto ed esplorato meno del
5%. e ancora solamente nel Mediterraneo
delle specie marine sono 2000 le nuove
specie che ogni giorno e ogni anno
aggiungiamo ai nostri registri
un mare grandissimo che però non
conosciamo molto bene essenziale alla
vita
e forse è proprio questo che ha sempre
attratto del mare Un po' l'ignoto il
mistero il fatto di non conoscerlo molto
bene
alla fine tutti i numeri che ho appena
parlato non sono altro che un modo che
la scienza ci dà per avvicinarci un po'
di più a questo mistero che però da
sempre ha ispirato la storia e la
letteratura
gli antichi greci e i romani per esempio
non riuscivano a darsi spiegazioni alle
navi che alle grandi masse d'acqua che
mandavano le navi a scogli
improvvisamente che oggi sappiamo sono
le correnti e allora un po' per
rispondere alle loro domande Si
inventavano storie leggende di mostri
marini come per esempio quello di Scilla
e Cariddi
Tra l'altro io oscilla un piccolo
paesino in Calabria non in Sicilia a
Messina ci sono proprio cresciuta tra
questi scogli qui è un po' Forse come
come facevo Omero guardando le correnti
e narrando di sirene io guardavo queste
correnti veloci come autostrade che
lasciavano quasi la scia negli scogli e
questi scogli che in anno in anno
cambiavano posizione con le mareggiate
invernali
ero curiosa ed estremamente affamata di
avvicinarmi un po' di più a questo
mistero
amavo i libri di storia letteratura però
a un certo punto quelle parole non mi
sono bastate più allora per cercare di
dare risposta alle mie domande ho deciso
di rivolgermi alla scienza
nei miei studi tra il Galles e
l'Inghilterra ho avuto l'onore di avere
accanto a me una persona che ha cercato
di dare risposte Anzi ne ha trovate
qualcuno ad alcune delle domande più
misteriose della biologia marina quella
dei mari profondi
nel 2018 Sono diventata assistente di
ricerca della dottoressa in software che
vedete qui un mito della biologia marina
internazionale in tutto il mondo lei
alla veneranda età di 87 anni con il suo
carrellino ogni giorno continuava a
recarsi presso l'associazione di
biologia marina inglese per fare ricerca
negli anni Settanta il governo inglese
diceva dobbiamo proteggere i mari
profondi e allora Eve è tutto il suo
team di ricerca partivano per spedizioni
nei nei canoni più profondi e misteriosi
della Norvegia andavano a raccogliere
campioni a scattare foto ma soprattutto
a raccogliere dati informazioni
io scannerizzavo aiutavo a catalogare
queste foto sognando anche un po' su
quelle storie di spedizioni
lavorare accanto a lei è stato
bellissimo però c'è una cosa che lei
ripeteva spesso che continua a
riecheggiare tutt'oggi nella mia mente
lei diceva cercare di proteggere il mare
senza però avere dati informazioni per
capirlo è un po' Come cercare di guarire
una malattia che però non conosciamo
davvero
i dati Infatti sono il linguaggio che
abbiamo a disposizione per interpretare
il mondo che ci circonda e di
conseguenza capire il modo migliore per
poterlo proteggere
non serve essere un esperto per capire
la gravità di un grafico del genere
colori sempre più scuri ci mostrano la
velocità di riscaldamento dell'oceano a
livello storico attuale e futuro e non
solo anche sulla superficie sotto i 200
metri e sotto i 1000
la situazione è gravissima ci fa vedere
veramente l'imminenza della crisi
climatica attualmente in atto però
questa gradazione di colori ci aiuta
anche a guidare le nostre azioni future
regolare le vele
Infatti sul report come questo della
committente internazionale per i
cambiamenti climatici si basano tutte le
nostre leggi legislazioni azioni per
mitigare la crisi climatica in atto
e alla fine rapporto come questi non
sono altro che un mucchio di dati
raccolti da ricercatori da stazione di
ricerca da navi da ricerca che Messi
all'interno di un computer ci ritornano
indietro scenari come questi come per
esempio fanno anche le previsioni
meteorologiche e questi scenari ci
aiutano a guidare le nostre leggi che di
conseguenza hanno un'influenza sulle
azioni che compiamo ogni giorno
Però come dicevamo prima il mare è
grande
e per avere delle degli scenari accurati
Ci servirebbero veramente tanti tanti
dati e gli scienziati come Ive in realtà
non sono tanti anzi sono veramente
veramente pochi
Ma allora com'è che possiamo raccogliere
tutti i dati di cui abbiamo bisogno per
proteggere la vastità dell'oceano
prendiamo una regata
tante barche che si sfidano a chi va più
veloce sfruttando la forza del vento
se guardassimo il sistema di
geolocalizzazione alla fine di tutte le
competizioni spesso ci ritroveremo
immagini del genere una serie di scie
colorate che poi sono risce della barca
che si intersecano e coprono spessore
vastissime
adesso immaginate se ognuna di queste
barche mentre Naviga avesse a bordo dei
sistemi per monitorare il mare mentre
veleggia
avrebbero raccolto dati informazioni
utilissime per proteggere un ambiente
che le fa stare bene mentre praticano lo
sport che amano
questo può essere applicato a qualsiasi
sport è un numero innumerevole di
connessioni in cui le persone che vivono
il mare attraverso gli sport all'aria
aperta diventano gli occhi e le mani di
cui la scienza ha bisogno adesso non è
che questa pratica l'ho inventata
proprio io si chiama Citizen Science
scienza del cittadino e risale circa gli
anni 80 Quando è stata inserita nel
dizionario banalmente
a me piace pensare però che connessioni
come queste giochi di squadra tra gli
sportivi e gli scienziati siano un po'
Come funziona un ecosistema Marino in
cui ognuno ogni specie ogni animale ha
un ruolo ben preciso che però non gioca
solamente per il suo benessere Ma per il
benessere di tutto l'ecosistema
il gioco è proprio fare le connessioni
giuste ed è quello che stiamo facendo
nella startup che abbiamo creato proprio
qui a Genova dove connettiamo chi ama e
vive il mare con chi lo ama e lo Studia
per proteggerlo
ve lo dico in parole povere Avete
presente Tinder l'applicazione di Rating
sì chi dice no non ci credo
esatto però invece di trovare diciamo il
compagno della vostra vita noi
connettiamo Gli scienziati che ci dicono
di Che dati hanno bisogno con gli
sportivi che vivono il mare ogni giorno
che li possono raccogliere
per esempio gli scienziati ci dicono che
hanno bisogno di dati sul pesce luna o
su altri animali di cui non conosciamo
la loro distribuzione dove sono più
fragili dove sono Se dovessi riproducono
E allora noi insegniamo le persone che
vivono il mare attraverso gli sport come
l'apnea alla vela la subacquea il kayak
chi chi più ne ha più ne metta come
identificare questi animali farci sapere
dove sono In quanti sono cosa stanno
facendo e di conseguenza noi possiamo
guidare gli scienziati per i luoghi dove
questi animali sono più fragili
o ancora di plastica in mare se ne parla
tantissimo però spesso le grandi navi da
ricerca non riescono ad avvicinarsi alla
costa per esempio alla Foce dei fiumi o
vicino alle nostre città dove
l'inquinamento potrebbe essere anche
Maggiore
e quindi noi cosa facciamo Ci
trasciniamo dietro ai nostri Kayak delle
piccole reti da monitoraggio che
rastrellano il mare Alla ricerca di
piccoli frammenti di plastica
microplastiche noi poi li mandiamo gli
scienziati che ci fanno sapere di che
materiale sono fatti le contano e quindi
cerchiamo di arginare danni
ho ancora ritornando alle barchette
della regata questa qui è Gin tonic
Se state cercando un drink non lo
troverete perché sto parlando della
barca
è una piccola barca di 6 metri e mezzo
un poco più grande di un kayak forse
neanche la lunghezza della scritta text
Genova
una piccola barca che proprio in questo
periodo il prossimo anno
attraverserà l'oceano Atlantico portando
a bordo non solo il suo velista da solo
anche una serie di piccoli sensori da
monitoraggio che potrebbero essere
utilizzati su tutte le barche in futuro
una piccola barca che Però potrebbe
contribuire a rendere più accurati
grandi report sui cambiamenti climatici
e di conseguenza influenzare le azioni
che compiamo ogni giorno
tanti sport che ci fanno stare bene per
tanti dati che permettono a noi e al
mare di stare meglio e tra l'altro i
dati che abbiamo raccolto finora ci
dicono che se agiamo adesso siamo ancora
in tempo
Nel 2020 i maggiori scienziati del mare
di tutta Europa si sono riuniti hanno
preso tutti i dati di cui avevano a
disposizione sul mare non ho messo in un
computer e hanno pubblicato questo
articolo che con una sola frase arredato
speranza a tutta la comunità di
Scienziati internazionali
Loro sostengono che un sostanziale
ricovero dell'Abbondanza struttura e
funzione della vita Marina potrebbe
essere raggiunto entro il 2050 se
giustamente le maggiori pressioni
incluse il cambiamento climatico saranno
mitigate
e questo è possibile perché il mare è
estremamente resiliente un po' come ci
sta dando una serie di campanelli
d'allarme che le cose non stanno
tantissimo andando nel verso giusto se
glielo viene data la possibilità
lasciandolo anche un attimino stare lui
si riorganizza sempre per permettere la
vita
quando da piccola guardavo i miei scogli
che si spostavano con le mareggiate
notavo spesso come le parti scoperte
degli scogli si riempivano di alghe di
altri animali nel momento in cui
venivano toccate dall'acqua salata
perché alla fine se ci pensate facciamo
uno sforzo immaginazione tutto quello
che mettiamo in acqua prima o poi a un
certo punto prende vita
pensate al sotto di una boh ho una barca
ferma in porta o anche noi Io
sinceramente ogni volta che mi tuffo in
acqua mi sento di prendere un po' vita
e forse la chiave per proteggere il mare
sta proprio qui
nel tornare a tuffarci nell'acqua salata
che ci fa stare così bene con curiosità
Però avvicinandoci sempre un po' di più
a quel mistero
Il naturalista David in uno dei suoi
documentari penso abbia riassunto questo
pensiero molto molto bene dicendo che
nessuno proteggerà
quello che non gli interessa e a nessuno
interesserà quello che non hanno mai
realmente vissuto
e se i dati sono lo strumento che
abbiamo a disposizione per proteggere il
mare allora andiamolo a vivere questo
mare tutti insieme facendo lo sport che
ci piace di più e mentre ci divertiamo
Ricordiamoci che tutti possiamo
partecipare e raccogliere insieme
veramente un mare di dati grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]